lol saison 3 ça commence maintenant
évidemment interdiction de rire carton
jaune mais obligation de tout faire pour
faire rire les autres
rendez-vous en finale et rendez-vous
[Musique]
qui est une descente de police on est en
train de faire Virginie là
pour moi c'est quasiment mission
impossible
pas trop l'idée de parler de moi en tant
que j'aime pas le mot non plus manager
comme un oiseau
la stratégie c'est qu'il fallait que je
rentre dans un personnage
le panier
de mourir de rire ça peut craquer très
très fort sur un regard une connerie
[Musique]
cette saison va être complètement folle
franchement j'en pouvais plus
le meilleur jeu par contre
[Musique]